this is Lakeside right here it used to
be they called it like one way in one
way out Big Sean's gonna be mad because
he's not gonna be ready to one but we're
gonna go see if it bother him anyway
make him a little mad
you know we're bringing people on who
who a lot of times aren't really used to
being on camera and aren't used to you
know talking publicly but you gotta
always remind yourself why you're doing
it in the first place and the reason why
we're doing is because I really believe
that these folks are the kinds of folks
that we should be listening to we're
proud and and honored and grateful for
the people that come on and we're really
grateful for the people that listen and
that's just real I know there's a lot of
podcasts out there and the fact that
people listen to this it's just it it
means a lot to us so it is
literally the fuel that makes me keep
coming back and keep wanting to do it
[Music]